devil fruits are one of the coolest
aspects of one piece and they just keep
getting stronger and more interesting
but one piece lied to us about the true
nature of devil fruits in their real
categories I mean just look at the na
fruit so could it be that OD is still
hiding a crucial piece of the devil
fruit puzzle could there be even more
special categories of devil fruits that
have not yet been revealed like God
fruits and Demon fruits let's break it
all down like it subscribe if you enjoy
seeing one piece videos like this one I
want to keep them coming if you haven't
joined the KnockOn by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell so you
don't miss future one piece videos
updates you're also helping us reach our
insane goal of 2 million subscribers
here on YouTube quick thank you to
Eternal Evolution for sponsoring this
video Eternal evolution is a mobile idle
RPG with strategy and gotcha elements
and it's a super fun and easy sci-fi
game that is free-to-play friendly and
features unique high quality designs
right now Eternal evolution is doing a
huge limited time collaboration with one
of my favorite anime Evangelion you can
unlock brand new collaborative Trip s
heroes from Evangelion for the first
time including AA 1 and Shinji AA zero
and Ray AA 2 and Asuka Eva 6 and kawaru
and Eva 8 beta and Mari get them right
now through the Epic collaboration
recruitment event along with other great
rewards and clear story stages to
receive even more massive rewards such
as aa1 and Shinji for free you can also
challenge bosses like the fourth Angel
Otis version and the ninth Angel Otis
version and you can receive insane
rewards every single week if you're a
new player and you participate in the
grand ceremony event you will receive a
free trip s hero Ravena along with a
bunch of other resources there are daily
tasks and events with awesome rewards so
the more you play the more you benefit
you can even earn through the AFK mode
so you can take it easy and enjoy
playing without having to grind try it
out for yourself right now just use the
QR code or click the link in the
description use promo code eeva collab
and experience the epicness of Eternal
Evolution and Evangelion at the same
time the code will give you three collab
recruitment and, 1500 diamonds but act
now because this offer expires January
4th just use the QR code or click the
link in the description right now now if
you live in a world that is full of
islands and surrounded by the ocean on
all sides you'd have to be crazy to give
up your ability to swim I mean one wrong
move during a quick trip to the next
Island and you're dead so what would
cause some of the strongest Pirates and
Marines in the world to willingly give
up their ability to swim even though
they're out sailing on the ocean pretty
much all the time well although anyone
who eats a devil fruit will never be
able to swim again in exchange they gain
an epic Supernatural power that makes
them even stronger but to be fair as I
will talk about in this video not every
devil fruit is created equal so let's
break down all the categories and
subcategories of devil fruits and let's
also include some examples of the
strongest and weakest devil fruits each
time just so you get a better idea of
how unfair life can be some give up
their ability to swim in order to gain
Godly Powers While others gave up their
ability to swim so that they could turn
into a freaking Jack jacket first let's
talk about the three main categories
starting off with loia no editor that's
Lugia not never mind loia devil fruits
are the rarest of the three main
categories and there are only 13 known
canonical loia devil fruits and another
three non-canon loas they allow their
users to utilize elemental powers like
snow smoke magma and other canonical and
non-canonical substances not only can
the users turn their entire bodies into
their respective elements but they can
also control that element in the space
around them we were first introduced to
loia fruits through smoker in log Town
way back in the East blue because his
devil fruit allowed him to literally
turn into smoke and become Untouchable
he quickly overpowered Luffy and at that
early point in the story smoker seemed
like an Unstoppable force and to be fair
unless someone has the ability to use
some pretty serious hockey almost all
loia users are unstoppable just by
turning their body into their element
the users can ensure that any physical
attack that isn't imbued with Hawk will
just pass through them however this does
mean that they are more susceptible to
specific environmental weaknesses Beyond
just not being able to swim for example
because crocodile is made of sand water
will make him vulnerable to attacks by
hardening his body and making him more
solid also if your ability is to turn
into lightning then someone who is made
of say rubber will not be affected by
your lightning attacks so you know pick
your battles outside of those specific
instances though loia fruits are
seriously overpowered well usually
they're ALS strong of course and any one
of them can certainly do some damage if
used correctly but some are clearly
stronger than others for example the
magum magu noi or the magma magma fruit
is A Step Above The Meta Meta noi or the
flame flame fruit in power so even among
loia Powers there is a hierarchy of
power and even though you might think
that Flames are cooler than magma that's
just the way it is unless you got some
kind of Ace in the Hole to balance that
out you will end up with a hole in the
ace at first glance it is easy to assume
that something like the magma magma
fruit or the G goo no me AK the rumble
Rumble fruit are the strongest of the
loia due to both their sheer power and
defensive abilities I mean I don't want
to touch or be touched by either magma
or lightning however if we're talking
about the very strongest loia fruit that
would have to be the yummy yummy no me
or the dark dark fruit which is used by
none other than Blackbeard the devil
fruit of Darkness has gravity altering
abilities almost acting like a black
hole it is able to suck anything or
anyone into its depths as well as the
spell them which Le leaves them pretty
banged up or even nearly destroyed what
makes this fruit so unmistakably
different from the others in terms of
strength however is its ability to
neutralize the effects of any other
devil fruit with just a touch so long as
the devil fruit users remain in contact
with each other this turns even the
strongest of enemy devil fruit users
into normal people and as you can
imagine this poses a massive problem for
any devil fruit user in a fight because
they're all used to fighting with their
Supernatural Powers but then they find
themselves suddenly powerless but this
ability is even more useful against loia
users as we saw with Ace because loia
users spent so much of their lives able
to completely avoid any harm or damage
many of them fight pretty recklessly
after all they don't normally have to
dodge so when they do take a hit it can
be very disorienting now the weakest
loia gray devil fruit would probably be
caribou's Numa Numa noi or the swamp
swamp fruit if it weren't for the
non-canonical toot ton noi aka the
syrupy liquid fruit used by Honey Queen
this is essentially the swamp swamp
fruit but worse the liquid fruit allows
its user to turn into and control an
unidentified liquid kind of like the
swamp swamp fruit does with swamps and
mud the two share the same weaknesses as
well if they find themselves in a space
where their normal bodies could not fit
they cannot revert back to their solid
forms which let's face it is extremely
inconvenient like you can just get
trapped by your opponent inside some
sort of Jar or something how
embarrassing what puts the swamp swamp
fruit above the liquid fruit you ask its
infinite storage capability is because
who doesn't need some some more storage
space much like the dark dark fruit user
the swamp swamp fruit is able to store
anything in its swamp honey Queen
however has no such perk and so she went
out pretty sad let's all pour out a shot
of Pepto-Bismol for honey Queen and then
let's move on to paramia paramia devil
fruits are the most common of the three
major categories they're essentially
devil fruits that don't allow their
users to transform into a specific
element or animal leaving all other
supernal possibilities clumped together
into the same category we are first
introduced to these fruits in chapter
one of the story with Luffy and is
gumgum never mind the first paramia
fruit we see in the story is actually
the devil fruit used by Future yonko and
knu's Greatest Inspiration buggy D clown
who uses the chop chop fruit the weakest
paramel fruit in my opinion is a tie
between the Jack Jack noi or the jacket
jacket fruit and the aawa no me or the
bubble bubble fruit the jacket jacket
fruit was eaten by Kelly Funk and lets
him turn himself into you guessed it a
jacket that's it he can be worn by
people and he can at least control the
person who is wearing him that said he
can't actually Force anybody to put him
on and he has to depend on other people
just to use his own ability like if he's
fighting someone at long range or if
he's fighting someone he can't wrap
himself around for whatever reason he is
completely powerless the bubble bubble
fruit was eaten by Khalifa and this one
lets her you guess it again make bubbles
these bubbles can be used to clean but
they can also drain an enemy's energy
which actually sounds pretty useful
unfortunately this power can be washed
away by water or can literally just Blow
Away In The Wind avoiding water is one
thing but the wind good luck with that
now having said that I absolutely love
this devil fruit because it gave us one
of the most complex and philosophical
scenes in the entire one piece series
The genre bending award-winning Khalifa
and Nami bath fight 10 out of 10 on the
other hand the strongest paramia would
have to be whitebeard's Tremor Tremor
fruit or the gura gura no me this fruit
can create Tremors and shock waves that
can travel through anything even the air
this basically made white beard feed a
walking magical earthquake machine his
power could have destroyed an entire
Island if you wanted to now while the
devil fruit is incredibly overpowered it
can be stopped by exceptionally powerful
hockey as we saw when Whitebeard tried
to take down Marine Ford's execution
platform his efforts were successfully
thed by all three Admirals using their
armament hockey now let's talk about the
third major category of devil fruits The
Zone devil fruit this devil fruit allows
its user to gain the powers of a
specific animal or mythical beast and a
Zone devil fruit user normally gains the
ability to change between three forms
human form human Beast hybrid and Beast
form one unique thing about these devil
fruits is that they essentially come
with their own personalities while there
are theories out there which suggest
every single devil fruit has its own
personality or as I believe that every
devil fruit carries some lineage factor
of all its former users within itself
but this idea about devil fruits having
their own will is especially true of the
Zone devil fruits while in their human
form Zone users keep keep their own
personalities while in Beast form users
will take over the identity that comes
with their respective devil fruits this
category of devil fruit has multiple
subcategories which are distinct from
regular Zone devil fruits this included
mythical ancient and artificial zones
which are further separated based on the
kind of Beastly category that they fall
into these include dogs cats humans
birds and snakes and more ancient zones
allow their users to transform into an
animal that walked the Earth in ancient
times but have since gone extinct or at
at least they're believed to have gone
extinct these include dinosaurs mammoths
saber-tooth tigers and so on some
ancient Zone users include queen as the
Brachiosaurus King as the Pteranodon and
page one as the spinosaurus the brutal
size and strength that comes with these
Transformations serves as an extremely
effective weapon against most opponents
and as we can see with our boy Jack and
his Mammoth devil fruit these delr users
literally cannot lose seriously Jack has
never taken an L in his entire life life
now mythical Zone devil fruits are
extremely rare maybe even rarer than
loia devil fruits the users of these
devil fruits have the ability to
transform into legendary creatures of
myth think Dragon Phoenix Cerberus seru
an eight-headed snake or even Pegasus
some examples of mythical Zone users
include Orochi as the offer mentioned
eight-headed snake soku as dutu or a
giant Golden Buddha and of course Monkey
D Luffy himself as the sun god NAA it's
like like having the power of Legends
gods and fairy tales in the palm of your
hand finally we also have to talk about
the artificial Zone fruit the
development and advancement of these
devil fruits would not be possible
without the genius of Dr Vega Punk and
Caesar Clown Vega Punk's findings were
developed through his research of the
lineage factor that belonged to actual
human devil fruit users while Caesar's
research focused on the lineage factor
of animals this restricted his work to
Zone devil fruits while Vega Punk
actually went on to successfully
duplicate the powers of paramia devil
fruits that said Vega Punk believes that
loia devil fruit powers are simply too
difficult to duplicate artificial devil
fruits still take away the user's
ability to swim like every devil fruit
and this will happen even if the fruit
itself ends up being a failure
artificial devil fruits take the shape
of an apple and have spots instead of
spirals Caesar clowns artificial fruits
are called the smile fruits smile fruits
are made with sad a chemical compound
formulated by Caesar Clown these new
Devil fruits are only successful 10% of
the time if you're one of the Unlucky
90% like the pleasures in the Beast
Pirates you won't inherit a special
power you will also lose your ability to
have negative feelings and will be
forced to smile and laugh for the rest
of your life which is probably why
they're called the smile devil fruit so
basically a guy named clown produces a
substance that makes people smile and
laugh uncontrollably sounds kind of
familiar the only thing missing is
Batman and now of course let's talk
about some of the strongest and weakest
Zone fruits obviously kaido's U Know
model seru aka the fish fish fruit model
Azor dragon is among the strongest in
this category kaido is able to turn into
the Eastern Dragon itself the sheer size
of this transformation alone gives him
an extreme Edge over his enemies and
that's before we get into the incredible
power that comes from this fruit a
slight movement from his beastly form
can cause shock waves and his Size
Doesn't hinder his speed and his scales
offer a nearly impenetrable defense even
against Luffy's gear three attacks kaido
also has a hybrid form and a whole bunch
of other powers and abilities but you
get the picture his power is truly in
the realm of myth and Legend the weakest
Zone fruit would of course be a faulty
smile fruit but that seems like a cheap
answer since it's artificial apart from
a bad smile the worst Zone fruit would
have to be the inuu no me model doxen or
the mut mut fruit doxen on top of having
the powers of a doxen which are I don't
know being long and sausy the doon's
actually a sickly breed of dog and this
would translate to its user now we have
basically covered all the main devil
fruit categories but this is actually
where the real fun begins there are
multiple subcategories that are shrouded
mystery and speculation and these are
the ones that fans love to talk about
because they are still so unknown and so
interesting I'm talking about awaken
devil fruits special devil fruits God
devil fruits and Demon devil fruits or I
guess you could call them devil devil
fruits but that's kind of confusing so
I'll stick with demon very rarely devil
fruits can fully awaken which makes the
devil fruit Powers much stronger and
often much more versatile the user also
has greater control of his devil fruit
power because with Awakening the user's
mind and body essentially come into
perfect harmony with the devil fruit and
its powers the devil fruit is no longer
something that the user consumed and
that alters his body the user and the
devil fruit become one The increased
power that comes with devil fruit
Awakening takes some time to master and
control but once the user Masters this
new power he becomes incredibly strong
it's important to note that devil fruit
Awakening is extremely rare there are
only about 15 known awakened devil
fruits both Canon and not canon that's
15 out of the like 200 Canon and
non-canon devil fruits total the nature
of a devil fruits Awakening depends on
the type of devil fruit involved
awakened paramia devil fruits generally
seem to allow the user to expand their
powers Beyond just their own bodies
essentially allowing them to imbue their
surroundings with the property of their
power in other words a paramia user's
power may be to transform his own body
in some way but once their devil fruit
awakens they will be able to transform
their environment in a similar way to
their body for example do flamingo's
itoo noi or string string fruit allows
him to create strings from his body and
then manipulate them in whatever way he
chooses but when his devil fruit awakens
he can turn even the surrounding area
such as entire buildings and the ground
into giant strings that he can
manipulate and he doesn't even have to
touch something in order to make it
string like meaning his a awakened power
works at long distance another example
is katakuri's moii no me initially this
devil fruit gives its user the ability
to create manipulate and even transform
into Mochi but upon Awakening the user
gains the ability to basically turn the
entire Battlefield into Mochi as well
which of course gives the user of this
devil fruit a massive home field
advantage Zone devil fruit Awakenings
are quite different from their paramia
counterparts Awakening gives the devil
fruit user a lot more strength speed and
endurance than they had prior to
Awakening and their ability to recover
from injuries also becomes greatly
enhanced however since Zone devil fruits
are known to have a strong will of their
own there is a danger that an awakened
Zone will literally take over the user's
original personality and turn him into a
wild beast the Jailer beasts from impel
down are believed to be an example of
this however it is certainly possible to
have a Zone devil fruit Awakening and
still retain your own personality as
seen with Rob Luchi and Kaku these guys
are also able to attain a new awakened
form which is an interesting hybrid form
between their beast and man forms now I
personally have the theory that kaido's
devil fruit has already awakened
initially it was The Magikarp fruit but
it became the Gyarados fruit upon
Awakening however that is just a theory
and it hasn't been confirmed but what
about Loi Awakenings well there has
never been a known Loi Awakening so
there isn't much we can say about it
however there is an unofficial
subcategory known as special devil
fruits and this refers to devil fruits
that don't quite fit within the normal
boundaries of Their Own own devil fruit
category Luffy's gug noi was seen by
many as a special paramia because of its
unique properties until it was
eventually revealed to be a mythical
Zone that said there are more of these
special devil fruits out there in the
past jimbe has referred to the mochii no
me as a special paramia and Blackbeard's
yumy yumy no me has also been called a
special loia that's because this devil
fruit doesn't quite follow the normal
rule set for a loia devil fruit the yumy
yam noi allows its user to control
darkness and the strong gravitation
force that resides within the darkness
the user can pull and absorb both living
creatures and inanimate objects into a
massive void where they can be stored
and regurgitated later unlike the other
normal loas the yamy yam noi does not
allow its user to Simply turn into
darkness and avoid all incoming physical
attacks instead the user will still be
vulnerable to attack even while using
his devil fruit power the yummy yummy no
me also seems to have an additional
ability that no other devil fruit
possesses this is the ability to absorb
and negate the powers of other devil
fruit users simply by touching them
lastly Blackbeard has found a way to
steal the devil fruits of others and
take them for himself allowing him to
use more than one devil fruit at once
even though this should be impossible we
still don't know how exactly Blackbeard
was able to achieve this but some
speculate that this additional ability
could be also the result of his strange
devil fruit which absorbs all things and
maybe even the devil fruits of other
people all the unique powers and
properties of the yam yam no me have led
many to claim that this fruit sometimes
referred to as the most dangerous Del
fruit of all might be some sort of
special loia or even another subcategory
entirely and that brings us to the final
the strongest and the most important
subcategories of devil fruits God devil
fruits and Demon devil fruits ever since
we first learned that Luffy's actual
devil fruit isn't the paramia type G noi
but rather the mythical Zone type he
toito noi model NAA there have been a
ton of theories about the existence of
devil fruits that are in League of Their
Own devil fruits with Godly Divine
powers that are noticeably stronger and
more overpowered than all the other
devil fruits in existence the real name
of Luffy's devil fruit actually sparked
most of these theories because NAA is
the name of an ancient sun god a deity
also known as The Warrior of Liberation
who has been worshiped by slaves and
marginalized and oppressed peoples for
countless centuries this means that
Luffy's mythical Zone isn't based on
just some mythical creature it is based
on an actual God and that certainly
called for paying special attention to
this devil fruit there is a big
difference between a flying horse devil
fruit or a snake with multiple heads
devil fruit and a sun god devil fruit
what's more back in skypia we were
actually introduced to four Gods who
were worshiped by the people of the sky
islands the sun god rain God Forest God
and Earth God and if Luffy has the sun
god devil fruit then could there be
other God devil fruits as well perhaps
the four God devil fruits that
correspond to the four gods of skyp we
know that Greenville has a forest loia
which makes his fruit a strong candidate
for the forest God fruit and the rain
God fruit may end up being monkey the
dragon's weather controlling devil fruit
so then what about the Earth God fruit
some have suggested that a major villain
such as emu might end up possessing this
one but others would say that we've
already met the user of this very fruit
after all Blackbeard's darkness loia is
special it has the power to absorb and
store everything like the Deep endless
Earth it has the powers of gravity and
it has the ability to negate the power
of other devil fruits at least
temporarily so what if Blackbeard's
devil fruit is not just a unique loia
but rather one of the very few Godly
devil fruits that gives its user Divine
Powers Blackbeard always believed the
yamyam no meat to be special so much so
that he specifically sought to find this
specific devil fruit and he was willing
to do whatever it takes to get it and
since we all know that Blackbeard will
be one of the main antagonists in the
final Saga of One Piece wouldn't it be
cool if Sun God Luffy had to face off a
against Earth God Blackbeard the God of
Light versus the god of Darkness the god
of the Skies versus the god of the
underworld finally the recent reveals
about emu and the Goro and their
absolutely insane devil fruit Powers
have contributed to the conversation
about God devil fruits and they've also
launched a conversation about the
possible existence of demon devil fruits
that are the dark counterparts of the
god devil fruits once the truth of what
happened to King Cobra and Sabo during
the revery was finally revealed we
learned that emu and all five of the
goday have the ability to transform into
large monstrous creatures with
animalistic features this has led too
much speculation about them potentially
having mythical Zone devil fruits and
this speculation was given further
Credence when one of the gor J garia
Saturn publicly revealed his devil fruit
in chapter 1094 first we saw a creepy
magic circle on the ground complete with
a pentagram like symbol that is
reminiscent of dark magic and satanic
symbolism Saturn then appeared inside
that Circle in his demonic devil fruit
form as if he was summoned by demonic
magic he still has his head and beard
but he also has big black horns the body
of a giant spider and swirly clouds
around his head and shoulders that look
just like Luffy's na clouds only black
instead of white this implies that
Saturn also possesses an awakened
mythical Zone devil fruit just like
Luffy needless to say Saturn is
extremely powerful and extremely deadly
in this demonic form and this is what
has so many fans suggesting that emu and
the Goro may have devil fruits that are
basically the dark counterparts of
Luffy's Godly NAA devil fruit if NAA is
the Sun God then these guys are devils
and demons and so on top of the Godly
devil fruits like NAA we may also have
demonic devil fruits like those that
belong to Saturn the other godo and emu
these Godly and demonic devil fruits may
not fit into any of the conventional
categories at least not completely and
they are likely to play a massive role
in the conclusion of the one piece story
after all we are now in the final Saga
and characters like emu the Goro
Blackbeard and dragon are surely about
to take center stage and since they all
appear to have rare and Powerful devil
fruits we can expect to learn a lot more
about these strange and exceptionally
strong devil fruits very soon the God
and Demon devil fruits may just be
extremely overpowered subcategories of
the larger categories of devil fruits or
they may turn out to be in a category of
their own who knows maybe these were the
Del fruits that were created first and
maybe these fruits hold the will of the
ancient deities who decided to create
the devil fruits in the first place but
what do you guys think are we going to
discover more Godly devil fruits
alongside Luffy's son God naika fruit or
do emu and the Goro have the dark
counterparts of these Godly fruits like
dark God fruits or demon fruits and what
about Blackbeard where does his strange
and unique yummy yummy no me fit into
all of this share your theories down in
the comments below now if you're looking
for an epic one piece video to watch
next check out this video about zoro's
real father link on screen right now and
that in the description thanks again to
Eternal Evolution for sponsoring this
video check them out right now Link in
the description like And subscribe to
help us reach our insane goal at 2
million subscribers here on YouTube and
I'll see you in the next one